they say you're either a numbers person
or you're not but one Sydney math
teacher is working to change that
misconception
Eddie Wu is on a mission to make
mathematics understandable and
accessible to everyone even enjoyable
believe it or not
here's unique and dynamic approach to
teaching has not only made him a
worldwide YouTube sensation but it's led
to Eddie being named as New South Wales
local hero in the Australian of the Year
awards and he's delivering the Australia
Day address next week I spoke with Eddie
earlier as a mathematics funnily enough
wasn't your strongest subject when you
were a student it certainly didn't come
naturally to you so how did you wind up
becoming a math teacher was that a
conscious choice it was definitely a
deliberate decision for me because I set
out to become a high school teacher
because I wanted to make a difference in
the lives of young people and that
personal journey particularly from where
you into high school to when you leave
and you're fully formed adult making
decisions for yourself and choosing your
own trajectory in life that's what I was
excited about and I wanted to do any
subject that would make me useful to
children in schools and the need was in
mathematics and it still is so that's
what made me leave to choose that
subject to teach you were happily
rolling along just being a humble maths
teacher were the only people who saw
your lessons were the students in your
classes at James ruse agricultural high
school I believe but then you started
putting your maths lessons on YouTube
which then became cold words you've
appropriately enough that was originally
for the benefit of one student tell us
how that unfolded I met a student who I
was teaching in year 10 and he was
diagnosed with pancreatic cancer which
is obviously incredibly violent and
aggressive for anyone let alone a 16
year old boy and we knew he would be
away from school for weeks at a time and
that's no way to learn anything but
especially mathematics many people say
to me I was okay with mathematics until
they started putting letters in the mix
or until calculus and from then on they
just never got got back on the horse and
I knew if this students experience of
mathematics this year was a substandard
and negative learning point for him he
just would never recover and so I
thought you know what I can do better
they say
with the textbook and saying good luck
I'll see you in a month so I took my
phone out I started filming my lessons
just within the normal classroom time
that I had with my classes and it just
sort of took off from there it's only
good takeoff I think you've got about
ten million plus hits on YouTube already
and it's you're an internet sensation
they call you around the world let's
just have a look at a little bit of one
of your videos what do I need to add on
in order to me
[Applause]
so there you have it the students are
completely intrigued there that you can
just you can hear the enthusiasm and the
penny seems to drop for them your skill
seems to be in packaging complex
mathematics in a relatable way how do
you do that Eddie well for me because as
we mentioned before mathematics was
something I struggled with as a student
I really need to understand something in
a simple way with metaphors and
analogies that will help me wrap my head
around what exactly is going on here and
why is it important and so as a
consequence that's the way I explain
things and I think students really enjoy
when they're struggling with something
someone who can identify with them and
empathize through that that hard to
understand process until the wife
finally comes on you know people tend to
say they're either a maths person or a
non-death person journalists always say
we're hopeless at maths that is
something that you just hate hearing you
believe maths is accessible to everyone
why is it so important that we all we
all get a handle on it well I think a
great metaphor here to help people wrap
their heads around what's going on is
that once upon a time we said exactly
the same thing about reading we said
there's a very tiny group of the
population who reads and writes that's
their job we call them scribes and the
rest of us we can get by without
literacy what is that there was
obviously no access to the printing
press to reading to widespread public
education and we got by and thought that
was fine but now from this side of
history we know much better we know that
reading is just integral to the way that
you can interact with the world and
society and mathematics is the same we
just haven't crossed that line yet to
understand on a broad cultural level how
important it is in terms of how woven
into nature and society mathematics is
it's so you
you see maths is not something that's
its own entity you say it unlocks an
entire world explain that to the non
that's people in the same way that once
you can read it's not just that you can
see a list of words and understand their
meaning it helps you have a perspective
on the way other people think and it
helps you engage with the world
you do not interact with in any other
way when you understand mathematics you
can sense the patterns around you you
can understand how to manage your money
you can see how your numbers for credit
cards and cash and logging in everything
that we do online is all kept safe by
mathematics and so seeing the way that
mathematical reality undergirds
everything that we do in our world is
kind of necessary in today's society
wasn't the other great appeal about you
as a teacher areas that you see suffer
so much more than a math teacher that
you very much take on the the personal
growth the responsibility for that
personal growth of your students it's a
very crucial time in their lives isn't
at the high school do you think that is
the responsibility of the education
system to do that I think that both
parents and teachers have this dual
partnership and responsibility to make
sure that young people are equipped not
just in terms of their academic skills
but also in terms of their character and
citizenship and the way that students
view the world and we need everyone
involved parents obviously have a huge
role in shaping the way that their
children think and feel about everything
they see in society but also in school
when we think about the vast number of
hours that children are spending
learning trying to understand English
history science maths we have a
responsibility as teachers also to give
students an understanding of how this
connects to their life in their everyday
sort of experience you're giving the
Australia Day address on Tuesday a great
honor and in that you'll also be talking
about growing up as the child of
migrants your parents were born in
Malaysia you were born here how much is
that shaped you and so it's a typical
Australian story isn't it it really has
been quite decisive in terms of my own
identity and what I have to bring to
Australian society and it took me a long
time to grapple with not looking Western
but not sounding Eastern and just trying
to find my place in this culture and be
able to say okay I have something
valuable
I have something unique and I want to
give that to the community and so you
know this is why I'm so excited about
being a teacher because it gives me
opportunity to tell young people hey you
don't know where you are that's the
character
Stickley adolescent challenge you don't
know what your identity is or what's
important in the world let me help you
discover what that is and find a way to
make a positive influence on